today on the matt welsh show the head of
the la teachers union admits that she
doesn't care about kids learning
academic subjects she just wants them to
be properly indoctrinated she may be the
one saying that out loud but that's how
the public school system has operated
for decades also the cdc has expanded
its reach beyond diseases and is now
fighting the scourge of gun violence
what does that tell us and you can can
you now lose custody of your kids if
you're not vaccinated that seems to be
the way things are trending plus in our
daily cancellation a firefighter in
virginia is under investigation for
making an allegedly racist symbol with
his fingers the story only gets dumber
and dumber from there we'll talk about
it today and much more on the matt walsh
show
you know if you're a certain age and
really if you're
my age or older even a little bit
younger you probably have a lot of your
old memories sort of tied up in
uh antiquated technology vhs tapes even
you know they used to have books we
called up photo albums with actual
physical photos in it kids you might not
know about that maybe you have the stuff
in a box you have it somewhere you have
an attic it's collecting dust it could
be destroyed um you don't want to leave
it there that's why legacy box is your
chance to have aging tapes films and
photos digitally preserved so the
essential people and moments from your
family's history can be revisited and
shared for generations this week legacy
box is offering 50 off at legacybox.com
wall so that you can turn a lifetime of
memories into a highlight reel the
service couldn't be simpler i've done it
myself and it's very very easy all you
do is just uh you take their kit
and you which is a box and you just put
all the stuff in the box that you want
to have preserved you send it to them
and they do all the complicated stuff
and then they send it back to you and it
could be stored on a the cloud it could
be on a thumb drive it could be on a dvd
whatever you prefer
really easy and you get all the stuff
back uh in a surprisingly short amount
of time with their traffic tracking
system you can monitor every step of the
process so you always know that your
originals are being taken care of legacy
boxes
a simple way to keep loved ones close
and has helped over 1 million families
restore protect their most cherished
moments so visit legacybox.com walsh
take advantage of this limited time
offer for fifty percent off and honor
the moments that have shaped your family
uh that's legacybox.com
walsh to save fifty percent of legacy
box.com
walsh you know i'm not sure if i've ever
said this before but i'm not a big fan
of the public school system maybe i've
mentioned that perhaps you've picked up
on that in the past i may have mentioned
it or time or two on second thought and
and for good reason there are about 70
million kids in our country give or take
and 50 million of them are in public
school so there's no other institution
that claims this kind of a hold on this
many kids almost all of them 70 at least
as a society we have trusted this
institution
to mold entire generations of americans
to to determine what they believe what
they think what values they hold
we've really handed our country over to
it over to this institution the public
school system and said here you know you
you
make our country into whatever you want
it to be this is this is totally up to
you
and we're suffering the consequences of
that decision but even now
many americans like to imagine that they
send their kids to public school
only for academic enrichment and
training only to learn the facts about
you know math and history and so on
but the system considers facts to be
secondary to its primary goal which is
to instill
values
uh it's not so much to tell kids about
the world
but to control how
the kids see the world and how they feel
about what they see
the indoctrination the point here is the
indoctrination is not a it's not a
byproduct
it's not a side effect
but it is indeed the point
of the system it's why the system exists
so that the state can form the younger
generations into whatever shape it
prefers
it's not a conspiracy theory that is why
public school came into existence for
that reason
so that the state would have control
over
the next generation and over molding the
country and if you listen very closely
to the people
who run the system
you'll hear them admitting to this fact
and actually you don't even have to
listen that closely because they
practically will shout it into a
bullhorn at this point so take this for
example this is a profile in la magazine
of cecily mayart cruz who is the head of
the los angeles teachers union
here's the second paragraph
like i said shouting into a bull horn
you don't have to listen even that
closely but this is where the second
paragraph of that profile says on a sun
on a sunny may afternoon my art cruise
is allowing a reporter inside her inner
sanctum or at least inside a
glass-paneled conference room down the
hall from her 11th floor office
and right away
she lives up to her reputation after
settling into a swivel chair and slowly
removing her zebra print face mask the
47 year old lightning rod for
controversy calmly sets her hands on the
table and begins issuing a series of
incendiary statements that almost seem
aerodynamically designed to grab
headlines and infuriate critics like
this one
quote
there is no such thing as learning loss
she responds when asked how about her
insistence on keeping la schools mostly
locked down over the last year and a
half and how that may have impacted the
city's 600 000 kindergarten through 12th
grade students
quote uh our kids didn't lose anything
it's okay that our babies may not have
learned all their timetables they
learned resilience they learned survival
they learned critical thinking skills
they know the difference between a riot
and a protest
they know the words insurrection and
coup
she even went so far as to suggest
darkly that learning loss is a fake
crisis marketed by shadowy purveyors of
clinical and classroom assessments
yeah it's a
learning loss is a conspiracy theory
she's saying
now she's right
in one sense that there is no reason why
kids
should suffer learning loss just because
public school has been shut down
so that teachers can have an 18-month
paid vacation
some parents picked up homeschooling
during that time and discovered that
their kids were learning more than they
ever had before
real learning begins
when you take your kids out of the
system that's when the best learning the
real learning happens but unfortunately
many parents didn't replace public
school with homeschool they instead
plopped their kids down in front of
computers for seven hours a day hoping
that their eight and nine year olds
would learn from zoom classes
just put their you know put your
nine-year-old in a zoom meeting all day
and hopefully pick something up and they
didn't pick anything up nothing absorbed
because nobody can really learn that way
or very few people can especially kids
can't
for many kids therefore public school
was replaced with uh with nothing
which admittedly
still might be an improvement
but that's not the point that miss cruz
is trying to make
she's saying that it doesn't matter if
our kids
our babies she says and she does mean
our as in like mine
um but it doesn't matter if they didn't
learn academic subjects because she says
they were still exposed to the right
political messages
they learned that when blm burns down a
city block
it's a protest but when people with maga
hats on riot it's an insurrection
and as far as she's concerned you know
if that's all they learned in 18 months
well it's good enough
right wing bad left wing good
that after all is the main thing i mean
it's the only thing she wants kids to
learn
through 12 years of grade school
in fact the kids who learned the
difference between a riot and a protest
quote unquote are probably ready to
graduate as far as she's concerned no
need for them to finish fourth grade
just send them all the way through
because for her again the indoctrination
is the point
here's another example if you need it a
teacher named kristen pitzen posted some
videos which have since gone viral
where she brags about how she took the
american flag down in her classroom and
now tells her students to pledge
allegiance to the pride flag
now this teacher after intense backlash
from the public has apparently been
removed from the class though they're
not saying she was fired
permanently they're just saying she's
not teaching the classroom right now and
keep in mind
and that's good you know that she's not
in the classroom she should be fired
this this is this is a time when someone
should be canceled
and there are a lot of people on the
left reacting to this oh i thought you
guys were against cancel culture
you misunderstand i'm not against
people suffering consequences the
correct consequences for bad actions
but that's not what cancer culture is
but keep in mind she was quote unquote
cancelled
maybe
but only because she admitted to this
and posted it to tick tock
and then only because the account libs
of tick tock on twitter took it and put
it on twitter and then it went viral
that's the only reason she's suffering
consequences
if she had just kept this to herself or
just posted it to her own tic talk page
and not and it hadn't gone anywhere else
she would still be in the classroom
right now
so that's all the backgrounds
and uh here's the video watch this
okay so during third period we have
announcements and they do the pledge of
allegiance i always tell my class
stand if you feel like it don't stand if
you feel like it say the words if you
want don't have to say the words so my
class decided to stand but not say the
words totally fine except for the fact
that my room does not have a flag it
used to be there but i took it down
during covid
because it made me uncomfortable and um
i packed it away and i don't know where
and i haven't found it yet
but my kid today goes hey um it's kind
of weird that we just stand and then you
know we say it to nothing and i'm like
oh well you know i gotta find it like
i'm working on it i got you
in the meantime i tell this kid
we do have a flag in the class that you
can
pledge your allegiance to and he like
looks around he goes
oh that one
hilarious but the american flag makes
her uncomfortable
doesn't bother explaining why we're just
supposed to understand why it makes her
uncomfortable
and hey if you're uncomfortable with the
american flag you don't like this
country
well join the join the club with all the
other people that are that are in your
boat
and um maybe actually get on a boat and
go go somewhere else in fact i hear
kabul is is nice this time of year why
don't you go there
if you if you're if
if you hate america so much that you're
uncomfortable around the flag
this kind of sentiment is would be
inconceivable in almost any other
country
in the world especially in the
non-western world
to have someone professing to be
uncomfortable around their own nation's
flag
but we not only have people who feel
that way here but they're teaching
students
and that was the only video there's
another one too here she is talking
about all the pride flags in her
classroom and she's got about a million
of them it seems but uh here's that
it's pride month
i will never not be awkward that's fun
for me happy pride everyone it's june
1st the start of pride month here's what
i got going in my classroom i got these
flags from target and like the dollar
bin so that's amazing
um they didn't have all of them in the
collection that they came out with so i
got all the ones that they had
as well as
the inclusive
pride flag
i pledge allegiance to the queers
i also got a really big pride inclusive
flag um i need to put it up still but
it's gonna go up there and i need like a
ladder
so that's gonna come later but it's here
yay so
i love you all very much for the people
who are out for the people who aren't
out you're appreciated you're loved you
are enough i support you i got you
now think about the culture in that
school and among the faculty
that made kristin pitzen think that it
was it was okay not only to do what she
did but to brag about it on the internet
think about what's happening in that
school think about what's happening in
the faculty lounges what kind of
conversations are going on
that she was able to do that and and of
course
again if she hadn't posted this to tick
tock and then if it hadn't been picked
up on twitter and gone viral there'd be
no consequences at all
and if it wasn't for the american flag
but the fact that she's draping her
entire classroom
in pride flags that's not a problem at
all
she wouldn't get in any trouble for that
even though we're told we got to keep
religion and school separate
separate church and state
and this is that's her church that's her
that's a her religious symbol
that is analogous to
only the sense of being a religion is
analogous but it is like
a christian teacher
putting the crucifix up in the public
school classroom i guarantee if they did
that there'd be a lot of problems they'd
get sued for it and they get fired
why because it's a religious symbol
now
does the constitution actually forbid
people at public school
teachers from expressing their religious
views and i don't actually think it does
but that's the precedent that's what the
left always says
and the pride flags are your religious
devotion that is your
that is your church that's your religion
that you're hanging in the classroom
but that would be okay
if not for all the other bits and the
fact that it went viral
this we always have to remind ourselves
when we see this
this is not an aberration this is not an
exception
this is the point of the public school
system
things aren't going wrong here this is
the public school system doing exactly
what it's supposed to do
which is why you know what i'm going to
say to end this off to end this
get your kids out of that system
now let's get to our five headlines
now i got a word from our very good
friends over at 40 days for life an
organization that does incredible work
uh in the country and for the on board
you know it's really easy to get kind of
nervous for for a lot of people when the
topic of abortion comes up in
conversation with friends families
family co-workers
i realize you know for me it's like i
talk about these things every day as a
job but for a lot of people that's not
your job you have something else you
have a real job that you do out there
and um that's why 40 days for life has
just released the perfect book for those
looking to arm themselves against a
broad range of pro-choice talking points
titled what to say when the complete new
guide to discussing abortion this book
is an easy read for individuals looking
to defend life
and
convert hearts a lot has changed since
abortion was legalized in 1973 what to
say when equips readers with proven
approaches to dismantling the
pro-abortion agenda
and uh even if you do talk about these
issues all the time it's still a useful
book it was useful to me and it was so
useful the fact that i actually wrote
the forward to that book uh which uh you
know
no big deal that's not the main point to
get the book but that that's also a nice
added bonus bonus so what to say when
the complete new guide to discussing
abortion you can get that now get free
shipping 21 off a signed hardback at
40daysforlife.com
what to say when
we start here with uh reuters says the
united states on monday completed its
military withdrawal from afghanistan
after a huge but chaotic airlift that
cost the lives of 13 u.s troops and left
behind thousands of afghans and hundreds
of americans still seeking an escape
from taliban rule
in a first in the nearly 20 years since
al qaeda september 11 2001 attacks
plunged the united states into war not a
single service member from the us
military was in afghanistan according to
the pentagon which said this in an
afternoon news conference heartbreak was
the word
that u.s marine general frank mckenzie
used as he described emotions
surrounding the us departure from his
longest war after dangerous and tireless
efforts by u.s troops to evacuate
american citizens and vulnerable afghans
um
it says more than 122 here's the number
more than 122 000 people have been flown
out of kabul since august 14th the day
after the taliban regained control of
the country 122 000
and we were told to begin with
that there were you know a few thousand
americans that needed to be evacuated
and there's still hundreds or even maybe
thousands of americans who have been
left behind
who have been abandoned behind enemy
lines lines by the bind administration
so what that means is that 122 000
people were evacuated
almost all of them were afghan citizens
and if the pictures and videos are any
indication
a huge number of them were men of
fighting age
who were evacuated and many of them are
going to be brought here
many
uh
certainly the federal government many
governors across the state as well
including republican governors have said
yeah bring them in bring them in
and and we're supposed to believe by the
way that the 100 plus thousand afghans
have been evacuated that they were all
they all what they were all interpreters
they were all translators
really
i mean how would we even know that that
mass of people at the airport
where were we sifting through them was
there some sort of real uh intentional
and careful process to see who gets on
the plane doesn't seem like it
i mean there are people literally as you
recall clinging to the outside of the
planes this was not a this was anything
but a careful process and that's all of
course biden's fault
but
these there's no reason to think that
all of these 100 plus thousand afghans
are coming here are helped america in
any way these are just people who wanted
to leave the country for good reason i
would want to leave it too if i was a
citizen of afghanistan
but just think about this
i mean there's there's nothing that
better encapsulates the ruling classes
attitude and approach
than the fact that they're bringing a
hundred thousand afghans here while
leaving americans in afghanistan
evacuate a hundred plus thousand afghans
and leaving americans there
america lasts every single time with
these people
america and americans last every time
next is from the daily wire says
referring to people as elderly uninsured
or in inmates is apparently dehumanizing
and not inclusive according to the cdc
and what appears to be a recently
published guide the cdc lists numerous
descriptors and phrases that it says
aren't inclusive before providing a list
of non-stigmatizing language
the guide includes multiple sections
grouping terms under banners like
disability and homelessness before
saying those words aren't inclusive
enough
wait a second
so
the
the guide uses those words
and groups people by those categories
and then says don't use those words
while they're using the words okay
for example under the disability heading
the guide says that words like
disabled
differently abled
and handicapped are stigmatizing and
should be replaced with lengthy phrases
like people with disabilities
or people who use a wheelchair or
mobility device
the guide says the cdc is aware that
some individuals with disabilities
prefer to use identity first terminology
which means a disability or disabled
status is referred to first for the
purpose of these guidelines cdc promotes
for person-first language
most of the guide is similar suggesting
the shorter identifiers wrong but simply
adding people with ahead of that to
apparently make it more inclusive um the
guides headlines are in alphabetical
order so the first section is titled
corrections and detentions and suggests
words like inmate prisoner convict
offender criminal parolee and detainee
are all stigmatizing
we wouldn't want to stigmatize
convicted felons who are in prison you
know they're convicted rapists and
murderers we wouldn't want we don't want
to step you don't want to make them feel
stigmatized i mean we're locking them in
a in a cell right for 23 hours a day but
don't we want to make them feel we don't
want to make them feel weird when
they're in there
so what are the terms we should be using
people slash persons who are
incarcerated
partner slash child of an incarcerated
person
people who were formerly incarcerated
persons on parole okay so don't say
parolee
say persons on parole
and then elderly is apparently wrong too
you can say older
adults and instead of saying underserved
people the guide suggests saying people
who are underserved
you see these
the pc
language just changes
i mean i can remember when i was a kid
there'd be a like a shift in pc language
it felt like every seven or eight years
they'd come up with a new word for a lot
of these different groups
and even that was kind of annoying i
remember we we people used to complain
back in the 90s about political
correctness going wild because you know
every every six seven eight years they
come up with a new word that we're
supposed to use
which which was political correctness
gone wild at the time and which was
absurd
but now it's like every seven to eight
hours they've got a new word
a lot of these words these are the
politically correct words underserved
people i don't even know who that's
supposed to refer to but that that is
a politically correct term
um
differently abled
disabled i mean what
differently able that is definitely
that's politically correct language
but no you got it you got to change it
up again
and why the arbitrariness is the point
again this is all about control
it's all about controlling if you can
control the words that people use
um
then uh then you can control their minds
i think there was some of the daily wire
actually wrote a book about this i think
now another question you might have is
why why is the cdc getting involved in
this the centers for disease control and
prevention what what in the world does
this have to putting aside how absurd it
is what does this have to do with
disease control
are people contracting diseases because
we're referring to disabled people the
wrong way
well no the cdc is expanding the scope
of their interests
uh to include now this is part of that
campaign
a focus on
gun violence
so this is supposed to be a big a big
historic moment we're told by cnn but
the director uh walensky of the cdc sat
down with cnn and talked about how now
the cdc
again they're expanding the scope of
their of their of their mission
and that includes policing
language but also
policing gun violence let's uh watch
that
but now in a stunning turn the current
director of the cdc is announcing a plan
to reduce gun violence sharing it
exclusively with cnn this is actually a
stunning moment that a director of the
cdc
is even talking about this issue is even
using the word guns
it hasn't happened in
years and years
every day we turn on the news and there
are more young people dying
i
swore to the president and to this
country that i would protect your health
um this is clearly one of those moments
one of those issues that is harming
america's health but there's a reason
why your predecessors didn't address it
one recent weekend in chicago we had 74
people shot
that same weekend a party in florida
five teenagers shot
that same weekend a man in new york city
in times square shot in the back
and
the list goes on and on
week after week after week
can anything be done about this
something has to be done about this so
40 000
uh firearm related deaths a year
120 000
serious firearm related injuries per
year the scope of the problem is just
bigger than we're even hearing about and
when your heart wrenches every day you
turn on the news
you're only here in the tip of the
iceberg
there's a reason your predecessors
didn't address it
well what she was getting at there is
that uh well they didn't address it
because it's politically charged and
it's they didn't have the courage
to address it
like uh like rochelle lewinsky does
who
look before we even get to what she's
talking about here
the fact that she still has a job
the fact that anyone at the cdc still
has a job they are the centers for
disease control and prevention
preventing disease
um
it would seem like the last 18 months
they haven't been doing a very good job
of that
how do
only in the government does it work this
way
where she's she she heads up
an organization that's supposed to
present prevent disease
and hundreds of thousands of people die
from a pandemic and and
she doesn't have to answer for it at all
now is it the cdc's
fault
no but
this this is their organization
preventing disease they certainly didn't
prevent this one
i mean this this is a time when if i
guess there's a way of putting if the
cdc has any
function if it if it serves any purpose
if we need the cdc at all
then you would think the last 18 months
would be the time when they would leap
into action and i don't know do
something i'm not saying they could stop
coving from existing but
maybe do do something
where would we be right now
in terms of covid and the death toll
if the cdc didn't exist
what if the cdc didn't exist
roshawlinski didn't have a job
uh or at least didn't have a job
in public life
where would we be
would anything be different
would there be one person who's who's
dead right now who would not be dead
um
would anything be different at all
or or maybe
are there people
you know alive right now
who are alive because the cdc prevented
them from dying of covet
i don't think there's any evidence for
that i think all the evidence suggests
that if the cdc didn't exist we'd be in
the exact same spot
we might be even in a little bit of
better shape
because the conflicting messages how
badly they bungled everything
it's hard for me to know how many people
have died because of that if anyone has
but
all the evidence suggests at least we'd
be in the same spot that way
but not only does she keep a job and the
cdc
retains all of its power and everything
and isn't is is not defunded
not only that but now they can expand
this is how it works in government when
you fail miserably
you are punished with more power and
influence and that's what's happening
and now she's expanding into gun
violence which just so you know is not a
disease
so that answers the question why didn't
your predecessor your predecessors
didn't address this well because it's
not within their purview because you're
the cdc it's got nothing to do with you
whatsoever
it's true though
talking about all the violence in places
like new york and chicago and our cities
i mean it is a crisis it is a it is a
an awful situation lots of lots of
people are dying
our cities have become like these
dystopian hellscapes
um but but but why is that
you know see for me the question is
always going to be yeah you got a bunch
of teenagers that were shot at a party
someone walked up and just shot all
these these kids all right go back to
that we talked about a couple weeks ago
um i think it was in new york a dispute
over shoes at a shoe store and someone
gets shot in the middle of the street a
guy who works at the shoe store he's
shot in middle street over shoes
and we see this kind of stuff every
single day in the city
and the cdc and you know the democrat
party
cnn the media
they want us to just ask the question
well how do you get his hands on that
gun we need a law that would make sure
that these people who are committing
these crimes
don't get their hands on guns to begin
with well we already have those laws
i don't even i haven't even looked into
the cases that were just mentioned by
cnn there but i can guarantee you to
begin with that almost all of them the
person firing the weapon
was possessing it illegally so he was
already committing a whole series of of
of crimes
simply by possessing that gun and then
certainly by using it the way that he
did so there are already a bunch of laws
but let's add five or six more on top
i'm sure that'll make a difference and
let's get the cdc on the case too
that'll definitely do something
so that's not really the question that's
not the most important question
the question is why would
someone even if they have a gun
why would they do that what is going on
with them
that they
have such indifference towards human
life
i mean i own a firearm i own multiple
firearms legally
and uh
you don't have to worry about me i'm not
gonna walk up to any party and start
shooting people i'm not gonna shoot
anybody over dispute over shoes it's not
going to happen
so there's there's something here it's
it's not just the gun right apparently
because i have one i'm not killing
anybody
it appears that like people
have these guns and they make choices
and so the real question that we could
be asking
is why are they making these choices
and if we want to narrow it down more we
could we could ask in the city
where violent crime is endemic
why are there so many people making
these kinds of choices
and when you start going down that
rabbit hole pretty soon you're going to
get the fatherlessness you're going to
get to the family you're going to get
all kinds of things that the media and
the cdc democrat party doesn't want to
talk about
all right speaking of uh the family
here's a man we're going to we'll play
this for you this is a guy plotting to
take custody away from his ex-wife
because she isn't vaccinated he's very
excited about this plan he's announcing
it to the whole world on tick tock um
here it is
holy sh
holy
holy
as a lot of you know i have a
five-year-old son who is with his uh
mother my ex-wife and her entire family
five days a week while he goes to school
in her district also as many of you know
she
and her family are all anti-vaxx
anti-mask
guess what she admitted to while i was
recording in my car on my property i
asked her point blank
are you covered vaccinated she said no
i said do you plan to be and she said
maybe i don't know
she said maybe i don't know i now have
hard proof of her admitting she is not
covered vaccinated around my son and
takes no precautions whatsoever and i
can subpoena video of her being in
stores unvaccinated with no mask with my
child i don't know for sure
but i think this could really help my
case
what a guy
what a man now you may hear this and you
think well
i mean that that can't really really
work i mean what
is it
not knowing anything else about this uh
this person's custody dispute i feel
like we already know just looking at
that guy and hearing we already know
everything we need to know about him and
none of it is good but you hear that you
think well that would actually work
could you could you take custody away
from a parent based on vaccination
status
and there's no precedent for that
uh as far as for as far as i know
but apparently um yeah it might work
this i believe is a separate case
but here's a report from fox 32 in
chicago
where in fact this kind of plan worked
out exactly the way that this guy hopes
let's watch this
a cook county judge here at the daily
center has stripped a chicago mom of her
parenting rights because she's refused
to get the covet vaccine and he is a
very sweet boy
he's my whole world
you miss him i miss him more than
anything
rebecca furlet has been divorced for
seven years and shares custody of her
eleven-year-old son with her ex-husband
what had been a 50 50 split in parenting
time but on august 10th in an unrelated
child support hearing cook county judge
james shapiro asked furlet whether she'd
been vaccinated when she told the judge
no because she's had bad reactions to
vaccines in the past judge shapiro
stripped furlet of all of her parenting
time until she agrees to get vaccinated
i think that it's wrong i think that
it's dividing families and i think that
it's not in my son's best interest to be
away from his mother ferlat is now
asking the appellate court to stay the
judge's order her attorney saying the
judge has overstepped his authority you
have to understand the father did not
even bring this issue before the court
so it's the judge on his own making this
decision that you can't see your child
until you're vaccinated
we just wanted the mother to pay support
the father's attorney jeffrey leving
says while they were surprised by the
order he believes the judge is making
the right call given the seriousness of
the pandemic
now the uh update here is that the judge
has reversed this the decision that he
made there because of public pressure
yet again
it's the right decision just like with
the teacher in the classroom but it's
only because of the public pressure
it's only because this case went viral
but the fact that it had to be reversed
at all
uh is very troubling
that this is where the trend is heading
and there are many people advocates for
the vaccine and masking are really clear
about this they they think if you're not
if you're not vaccinate if you don't get
your kids vaccinated
if you're not wearing a mask if your kid
isn't wearing a mask then you're an
unfit parent
you know you're putting your child's
life in danger you're basically killing
your own children
you're unfit and you shouldn't be
allowed to have custody of your
children that kind of rhetoric is
very prominent among the mob and in the
media
and now it's seeping into the court
system and that's a troubling
development to say the least uh next we
have this olivia rodrigo said um who of
course i'm you know i'm a big fan we did
it we did a whole video i think olivia
rodriguez she's the driver's license one
right she made that one yeah we did a
video about that
uh just a tremendous
uh i think masterful piece of art
but she said in an interview that she
she didn't know that non-white people
could be music stars
this is from page sixes olivia rodrigo
knows the impact she has on fans of
color revealing in a new q a that she
herself once believed only white girls
could be recognized as true pop stars
when saturday night live star bowen yang
asked the brutal singer how her
filipino-american background factors
into how she approaches her career she
said it's something incredible to think
about
she said i sometimes get dms from little
girls being like i've never seen someone
who looked like me in your position
and
these are girls that apparently have
like never turned on the tv which which
is great actually
and i'm literally going to cry like just
thinking about it
rodrigo said in a v magazine feature
i feel like i grew up never seeing that
also it was always like pop star that's
a white girl these days however rodrigo
is grateful that the music biz no longer
forces artists to be confined by certain
genres at least not to the extent that
she witnessed growing up
that she she's 18 years old
she was born in the early 2000s
when at at that point and
for much of the history of pop music
that like some of the biggest stars were
non-white people
and that again has been the case since
the advent of pop music
so this is uh you know
this is someone who has
absolutely no knowledge
of anything that happened prior to the
moment that she was born
and apparently even a lot of things that
was happen that were happening when she
was born
and through her you know her own life
she's she's been unaware of
which has led her to believe that uh she
somehow in the year 2021 as an 18 year
old pop star non-white pop star she's
somehow
groundbreaking
uh
i think you know i i hate to keep
beating on a dead horse here but this
goes back to the public school system in
a lot of ways
not that i really want them to you know
be teaching the history of pop music but
it's just this is another symptom of
what we find
among a lot of people not just young
people but especially among young people
today
that absolutely no knowledge of anything
that happened prior to their birth
and they don't think that any of that is
relevant as far as they're concerned the
world
as far as olivia rodrigo is concerned
the world
came into existence
along with her she basically created the
world by existing
which is uh
you know in some ways a very encouraging
way of seeing the world because then
you're constantly since nothing happened
before you you're constantly setting new
trends breaking new ground even if that
ground has already been broken a
thousand times before you existed
all right finally this is a very
important piece of audio and uh really
everything's been leading up to this i
think this is the most important thing
that we'll discuss and and play today
um i'm sorry sorry to get a little bit
serious here but something happened at a
henrico county school board meeting
a couple of days ago that uh
i just think you need to hear listen to
this
you guys work for us in in in this
environment you answer to us and i'm
asking that you do not pass this policy
in virginia
thank you so much mrs thomas we do
appreciate you
phil mccracken
phil mccracken
sulk souk
mahitik
[Music]
[Music]
i leaned over
eileen dover
don kittick
[Music]
wayne kerr
wayne kerr
i
i don't know why all those people
weren't weren't there it's it's it seems
you know they all signed up and didn't
show up i don't know if they're maybe
there's some other uh party or meeting
they were attending i'm i'm not sure i
also i can't believe that mr hunt
uh first name mike was was uh wasn't
signed up for that meeting either so
i don't know who did that but they're a
hero okay
they are and i mean i mean i don't know
if it was an adult or a child who who
did that but um
heroes either way an artist
and i and i hope it was a kid actually i
hope kids are still doing stuff like
that
that that makes me feel better that's
one that's one
glimmer of hope that i have now for
future generations
because that prank
it never gets it's always hilarious it
never gets old
and i don't see how that guy i
understand the first few names you don't
really know what you're getting into but
once you get to i leaned over
how does it how do you not figure it out
then
that is uh i'll tell you something
that is
much more important
and powerful
than
any other speech or anything that's
happened at these school board meetings
including the one that i gave
i bow down to that
um
well i don't bow down to it but you know
maybe that's the wrong phrase to use
okay let's use let's go now to reading
the youtube comments this is from the
fashion assassin he says my guess as to
why matt isn't on camera today is he
attempted the milk crate challenge
and failed miserably now he looks like
tom cruise from vanilla
sky trevor says matt isn't video list
today he's just resting his eyes
dh says apparently matt's fashion faux
pas was so egregious today that the
producers wouldn't even allow us to see
it
william says i think matt shaved his
beard but it looks so terrible that he
won't go on camera until it's grown back
okay lots of theories about why i wasn't
on camera yesterday but i'm going to
tell you the truth the truth is that i
had i had a flare-up of of leprosy
and it kind of comes and goes
and it's hard to tell sometimes because
my normal just my normal face sort of
looks like it but i didn't want to be
seen and i hope you understand that's
the real that's the real reason
uh
dick samerone
i don't know if i'm getting pranked by
that name
says are we being punished for making
fun of matt's outfit choices
gibberish says daily wire how do you
expect us to enjoy the benefits of the
bicep cam when you don't show matt on
the screen
andrew says by not having the podcast in
video form today matt has bravely
demonstrated what a world without white
people would look like this is
performative wokeness at its best well
done matt okay so basically every
comment is about the fact that there's
there was no video yesterday every
single one um
old school says matt didn't want to go
on camera today because his wife forgot
to do laundry and all there was left was
his skinny jeans
and polka dot shirt well that can't be
it because i don't own skinny jeans
first of all and the polka dot shirt i
will wear
proudly as you know but thank you for
all of those very useful comments which
have made for i think a pretty
interesting segment of the show
you know it's never been more important
to understand what's going on in the
political sphere and that's why we
started our newest podcast morning wire
the daily morning show which is
dedicated to bringing you all the news
that you need to know and also bring it
to you in 15 minutes or less because
they value your time and also the truth
and while we're working overtime to make
sure that this fact-based news still has
a platform we need your help to get the
word out to more people so make sure you
subscribe start listening now to
boarding wire on apple spotify or
wherever you get your podcasts and make
sure to leave that five star review if
you like what you hear also
you know there's the legacy media and
then there's the daily wire and if you
want the news that no other media
outlets will cover then i highly
recommend you sign up for a daily wire
reader's pass if you sign up today
you'll get a free week for a free four
week trial and that's the good part
that's a free month of the reader's pass
where you get access to all kinds of
great editorials and analysis op-eds
from ben shapiro candace owens even
myself on occasion
but the other good thing is that once
the four weeks is over and you decide
you want to you know really get uh
get it for longer it's only four
dollars a month that's it you're only
paying four dollars a month for all of
that content so go now to dailywire.com
subscribe and get this free four week
trial today and remember our offer ends
actually today on august 31st so this is
your last chance to get it go to
dailywire.com
subscribe now to our daily cancellation
[Music]
you know if you still don't believe that
there is a racism crisis in this country
then let me tell you a story that may
change your mind
according to an urgent and exclusive
report from fox 5 in dc a firefighter in
alexandria has been put on
administrative leave because he made a
controversial gesture while on camera
during a recent news segment
and this firefighter it appears moved
his fingers in a in a way
that may seem totally benign and
incidental to the untrained observer but
the heroic investigative journalists
over at fox5
know that quite often the most insidious
forms of racism can be hiding in plain
sight so we'll play this report for you
now and it's it's a little bit long but
it's it's worth listening to every
single moment of this and keep in mind
as you listen to it
this is very real okay this is not a
parody not a joke at least not
intentionally
listen to this
well only on fox 5 an alexandria fire
department member is in hot water being
investigated for possibly flashing a
racist symbol on our air fox 5's
stephanie ramirez is live in alexandria
at station 4 and stephanie how did this
end up happening
well rob this was during a live fox 5
zip trip segment that we were doing last
friday we do these in the community to
highlight different communities all
across our region well during the last
friday event in alexandria a fire
department member decided to flash what
is the okay gesture as the camera was
passing by we confirmed with fire
department officials today that that
member has just been placed on
administrative leave with pay now it
happened so quickly it's kind of hard to
catch here but it is the last alexandria
fire department member on the right who
first makes fists and then does that
okay gesture just before the camera cuts
to our two anchors a viewer email came
into fox 5 shortly after with a screen
grab of this member the emailer asking
why there's a gang symbol on tv stating
it needs to be addressed we asked the
department about it now we should note
here the okay hand symbol it was used as
part of a punching game if you flashed
it it is used by scuba divers
communicating underwater it's also
listed by the anti-defamation league as
a gesture of hate sometimes used to
express white power now i did get to ask
the fire chief today about it if he knew
the members intention behind doing this
chief corey smedley told me no that he
has not talked to this member yet but
there will be an investigation i also
asked what if it turns out that he was
or this was done out of some kind of
joke
a joke is only if
someone is not offended by it
and it's always in the eyes of the
beholder and just because someone may
have thought things were a joke it does
is not something that is
up to our values within the department
so we have to first and foremost make
every attempt to maintain the integrity
and trust of the community and joking is
not something that is part of our
mission
it's hard to know where to begin in
sifting through this madness the anchor
reporting live from the scene of where a
dude moved his fingers
says that the okay gesture where you
form a circle with your index uh finger
and thumb is a gesture of hate
well more specifically she says that it
can be it could be part of a punching
game
or it it's a sign
used by scuba divers divers uh or it
could be a secret white power symbol
those are the options
son you're either a scuba diver or a
nazi
and we ain't under the ocean right now
so that kind of narrows it down a little
bit of a full metal jacket thing going
on i guess
she does clarify of course that the adl
the anti-defamation league has declared
that the okay sign is a hate symbol what
she doesn't explain however is why
anyone should give a damn
what the adl thinks
there's a handful of far-left political
groups the adl southern poverty law
center principle among them that have
appointed themselves sort of arbiters of
of what is hateful and what is what is
not and they get to decide which
gestures and words and ideas and groups
are valid and which are abhorrent and
accursed we're not supposed to ask why
or rather where they derive this
authority or why we should respect or
care about their opinion on these
matters
the media will simply say well the adl
says this is hateful so
well i care what they say
why should who who put them in charge
it's not unlike the groups that have
declared themselves fact checkers
and now because they have fact checker
in their name they're meant to be
unquestionable
unquestionably trusted as as the
official adjudicators of truth
but the funny thing is that
if you go to the adl's official website
and their database for hate symbols it
does list the okay gesture and yet it
admits that the whole white power
connection is really a trolling campaign
by 4chan so here's what their website
says it says
a common hand gesture that a 4chan
trolling campaign claimed in 2017 have
been appropriated as a symbol meaning
white power
used by many on the right not just
extremists for the purpose of trolling
liberals
the symbol eventually came to be used by
actual white supremacists as well
caution must be used in evaluating
instances of this symbols use okay so
the okay gesture could be a white power
symbol allegedly or it could be a scuba
diver sign or it could be a game that
you play where if somebody looks at the
circle then you get punched that's when
i was a kid that's
that's what that's what that's that's
what it usually meant when someone did
that it meant that the punch was coming
shortly after you saw it uh or it could
be a 4chan troll or it could just mean
okay
or it could mean a dozen other things or
it could mean nothing at all
not every movement a person makes with
their fingers has some deep-seated
reason behind it in fact most movements
don't most are incidental
if you were to stare at a person's hands
long enough
and film it
looking for hidden meanings you know
behind every twitch or gesture you'll
come away thinking that they might they
made white power symbols they they
flashed gang symbols they flipped you
off they i don't know they they said the
words train and dog and sign language i
mean all kinds of random things
and the person will have communicated
these messages
to you without knowing that they
communicated anything at all
kind of like the truck driver for the
gas company in california last year who
was fired
for making the same white power sign
when really it turned out he was just
cracking his knuckles which is a pretty
you know you do this and you crack your
knuckles
also he's mexican but they still fired
him
for being an advocate of white power
but somehow we haven't even gotten to
the dumbest part of this alleged uh
news report yet
because the dumbest part comes to us
courtesy of the fire chief chief smedley
a perfectly appropriate name somehow
it's it's just
you hear chief smedley and then you you
see him and you listen to him and you
think well yeah that's
that's exactly what i expected from
chief's medley so chiefs medley says
that uh even if the benign probably
incidental finger movement
was actually intended as a joke
it doesn't count as a joke anymore if
someone gets offended exact quote a joke
is only if someone is not offended by it
which i guess that's news to uh
that would be news to to uh i mean
many comedians richard pryor was it was
apparently he never told a joke in his
life his whole career
we think of him as an iconic
trailblazing comedian but uh he's not at
all he's he was not a comedian he was
not a comedian because he offended
people with every joke that he told
but it's all in the eye of the beholder
chiefs medley says and if someone hears
or sees your joke and decides that they
don't like it
then all of a sudden your joke isn't a
joke anymore
if they interpret it as something
serious then that means that your
intentions were serious so they get to
retroactively determine
what your own intentions were based on
how your joke makes them feel
that's chief's medley's position
that's the media's position
that's everyone on the left that's
that's how they look at it
that's why he says joking is not a part
of our mission
that's the most chief smedly thing
anyone has ever said joking's really not
a part of our mission here
but this this this idea
which has led to the the unjust
cancellation of many a person
this idea that your your intentions
don't matter at all
in communication
so when you're communicating something
what you intended in communicating it
makes no difference all that matters is
the the person listening to it and how
they feel when they hear you say it
so even if you weren't trying to
communicate anything at all even if
you're just standing there and moving
your fingers randomly
and there's no intention
doesn't matter because someone felt
differently and they get to decide what
your intentions were not you them
all of this is quite insane of course
and it would be hilarious if not for the
fact that an innocent man's life is
being severely impacted by it just
imagine imagine from the firefighter's
perspective for a moment here
fox 5 shows up because they want to do
some dumb filler
um and you have to put on your uniform
and stand there for the b-roll shots and
they probably did a whole bunch of shots
you're standing out there for you know
45 minutes next thing you know
because some hyper-sensitive tattletail
with no life and nothing better to do
was offended by the movement of your
fingers now you're under investigation
and suspended from your job
and being smeared on television as a
suspected nazi
and to make matters worse it's being
done by people who almost certainly know
better
they're not as insane as they appear to
be maybe the original person who
reported it
the viewer who saw that and paused and
said what's that there what do you do
with his fingers
that person might just be a psycho
lunatic or simply a loser with nothing
better to do as i said
but the fire chief
well he's a spineless coward
the reporters are sadistic propagandists
perfectly willing to destroy a random
person's life for the sake of a story
especially a story
that advances the preferred narrative
and for all of those reasons that is why
of course fox5 in dc is canceled and i
have to say most of all
and i never thought i'd have to say this
but chief smedley you are also sir
canceled and that is no joke at all
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pablo vadasky
the show was edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio's mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
2021
america officially ends the war in
afghanistan the pentagon and the state
department have no idea how many
americans they left behind and new york
city teachers protest the city's covid
mandates check it out on the michael
knowles show
[Music]
you